here please get off of me get off of me
get off of me get off of me stop
touching me tell get off of me right now
let me go let
me she's got mental issues can let me no
youie are you done no I'm not sitting in
car if you touch me again I'll sue you
no you won't yes I will for on the
ground no he didn't no he didn't yes he
did I'm your mom did you not that
everybody watching you here my car is
broken my car is know what it's a car
you're about to get
arrested their cars AR falling why the
one that's broken they're calling the a
car for you I don't give a you need to
respect the police our family are police
officers all dirty nasty corrupt pigs
all of them are all of them are thanks
to social media all of them are all of
them are when they get here they are not
touching for what I'm sitting here like
this who am I they're not touching to
the road cuz he put me here he put me
right here yes he did put it on camera
play that camera back that camera back
and he threw me down play camera back
right
now Mom now we're done now we're done
okay we're done okay we're done I didn't
do anything you
do not move you understand me do not
move what are you doing do not move what
are you
doing nobody was touching you you're
pedophile pedophile touching me I think
so
ma'am get anything to you are you done
with your mouth no get me up I can't
breathe you can breathe just fine I
can't you're screaming and yelling you
can breathe just F
de I can't
breathe I can't breathe you can breathe
just fine dear good then let's roll over
then let's roll over there now you're
fine
help help help somebody
help help you're fine
help help
a
help help why did you do this not
turning face me why did you do this cuz
the way you're acting why did you do
this I wasn't touching nobody I wasn't
doing anything so why do you do this
what do I do you're this way this is
just going to make me more mad why would
you do this that's unfortunate why would
you do this why would you act the way
you act okay we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this body cam
video I mean I think it's pretty clear
from the body cam cams that we cover
that it's not always safe out there when
you're hurt it can be confusing it can
be scary you don't really know where to
turn well Morgan and Morgan is actually
the largest injury law firm in America
and in a time when you already have so
much to think about they're going to
make it super easy for you they have
completely modernized the process
because you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents you talk
to your whole legal Team all on your
phone that's it an attorney is going to
review your case in just eight clicks
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone why would
you because my car is crashed sir and
it's a car and it's my car and it's a
car just look you up no you can't look
at me stay seated Because I Said So then
get your neck off of my neck I'm sitting
right here get your hand off my neck it
hurts sir it I'll SC poers you're not
get off me mommy is hurting me I'm not
hurting you he's hurting me are you done
he's hurting
me he's hurting me that's enough no he's
hurting me enough help help he's hurting
me you need to stop he's hurting me you
need to stop do you understand me he's
hurting me he asked you to go set in the
he asked you to sit in the car and you
wouldn't do it you know now you're being
arrested no I'm not you probably are no
I'm not you did not do what he asked you
to do was simply set in the car I
shouldn't have brought you here I didn't
know where to get to lose look at my car
yeah can you get my shoes in my person
who cares about your car you're getting
arrested I don't give your car you're
out of
control you did exactly what I told you
not to
do you didn't do what he asked you to do
I was mad about my
car car am I getting arrested yes for
what l
l what I talk one second what am I
being yet okay hold on stay right stay
right here up against the wall luk come
here please
need to stand up I hurt yourself legs I
can't feel my
legs I can't feel my legs need to stand
up I can't feel my legs man come on I
can't feel my
legs
C in the car to go home one step at a
time I can't feel my back off now I need
you to leg need to stand up then you to
stand up stand
up my leg I can't feel my legs I'm
serious I'm serious I can't you to stand
up have a seat in the
car have a seat in the
car seat in the car face me
so yes you
can stand up you have a seat in the car
there you get in the car now sopia
listen to
them
[Applause]
Sophia you need to stand up need to
stand up need to get yourself hurt okay
we need to get you inside the
car Sophia you need to stand
up let's go come
on you did this to yourself
go P her that way a little bit okay
stop stop it you're making a fool of
yourself Lean Forward stand
up ow ow my arm is poed ow it poed no it
didn't now poped it stand up stand up
you can stand
up I can't I'm so scared stand up you
kick it with so
scared I'm so
scared
get in the car
[Applause]
now she wasn't even involved she's the
owner of the white car that was total
her boyfriend was driving she came here
comes out of the car screaming I'm like
well this will be great goes over does
her thing comes over and just wouldn't
stop yell and screaming doing crazy I
get back in the car and it was downhill
from there yes
sir I just can't
wi oh my goodness so Morgan crash out
here and the vehicle owner shows up and
uh she's not even in the crash but it's
her car her boyfriend I guess who wasn't
supposed to have it uh got in a crash
really not a big deal but she is
carrying on dramatic going freaking La
so I I let it go for a while Tred to let
her mom handle it it was not it was kept
escalating escalating she's screaming at
him getting his face she's screaming
causing a SC there's car stop been over
here looking at us the other people
involved looking at us I'm like well I
have disorderly at best so I'm like all
right so I try and talk to her I'm like
look you need to calm down try and talk
nice to her and then she kep going and
going talking over him like I'm done so
I charged at her get back in the car
kept pushing her you know pushing her
verbally back get out of my face I'm
like no you need to get in the car so
she wouldn't she turned and and started
like to go off again so I grabbed her
and then she of course said oh it went
to the ground and it starts going crazy
again like I pushed her on the ground
blah blah blah I'm like no dear so I let
her go she sat up waited waited waited
then she tried to get up again and storm
off so I'm like nope we're done so I
grab her when we go to the ground and I
cuff her and that's pretty much it now
she's saying on my shoulder and uh she
faked passed out so I'm like we're going
no matter what now if nothing else it's
it's resisting but I guess I can try and
get statements from these people over
here who are probably not going to want
to be involved so we'll see what happens
it happens quick so just FYI they
can't sorry about what's going on here
no I mean it's my fault she have brought
her here I knew she was this is equally
my fault because I knew she was I knew
this she was really upset but she's has
issues my fault I needed to get him and
try to
get turned 18 you know the summer so she
was extremely upset because we don't
have coverage on our
car we told her your car that's it we
can't get you another car you're
covering other people not yourself right
right that kind of is hurts but but
because she's younger you know you cover
her car and that car that's already paid
for the car we bought it straight up
nevertheless so she was upset about it
because you know she's thinking she
doesn't have a car she's got a new job
how are they going to get it back to
Gainesville they were fighting before he
left today which is probably partly why
you know I know the road was wet but it
doesn't help when you're not driving
when you shouldn't drive emotionally
nevertheless we got here officer Meadows
is fantastic great guy trying to go
through she immediately when she saw her
car started just going crazy screaming
yelling upset and everything about her
car being very dramatic obviously to
upset Luke as well but not fake cuz I
know it was true but again it should be
my fault I should have Dr over here but
I had no choice I needed to try to get
him I need to try to get the car I guess
I had a choice I should have just kept
driving for but nevertheless she just
wouldn't listen to anyone to calm down
he was very nice ask her you stop stop
yelling he asked her to go sit in the
car I asked her to sit in the car she
just wouldn't do it you know and um cuz
she was so emotional like of not
understanding about anything else that's
going on thinking about the car and her
job and now she's really scoping the job
she's got a brand new job doing really
well not a good thing so I tried to tell
her on the way here if she didn't if she
doesn't control herself Not only would
she not have a car today but she would
get arrested today and that's not
something that she needs to do so I
thought she completely understood that
but I think she still thinks she's a kid
because she hasn't been 18 for very long
and what happened to her cuz she's been
Baker acted for being extremely
emotionally like do not like
understanding or calming down that that
doesn't that's not what happens with you
when you're a kid you know you don't now
you things are all different but anyway
he was very nice he tried to work with
her she didn't listen to him she did
when he asked her to do so he he grabbed
her thing her hand but she she did quite
full away everything that he did was
fine my parents my mom was I with family
so I get it and you guys St like a
anything right now and kids nowaday are
disrespectful all the social media just
bad they not all right he was more than
patient I I do wish that I could have
had one more chance now that she
realized that she would be getting
arrested I don't think she thought she
was getting arrested or she was going to
get arrested she feels Justified that
she's upset but not that anything else
you know like that you know so I wanted
to try to get more chance get her
because I really don't 11 I don't know
what's going to now she's going to lose
you as well cuz she just di so a lot of
things are going B from that but maybe
be a learning lesson for her cuz I told
them you know in a way I'm not as upset
because I think she needs to learn but I
also don't think she can actually help
it as Mom because she's been having
these little like anger issues she's
like 5 years old you know so it's like
now I feel like it's my fault should
have brought her here this would to
happen God maybe it would have happened
at home when I got him home a damic
fight and the Poli been at our you know
what I'm saying so but either would like
I just feel really bad he was fine um
she was very disrespectful and rude um
which I sure is not appreciated and it
is what it is I mean it is what it is I
mean it's unfortunate I'd love to take
her home and not have her rest but I
also
understand he was very very paent he
yeah he didn't hurt her he didn't twist
her she said that but I don't think I
think she thinks that but that's not
what happened so you saw everything I
saw everything happened he did
everything by the book it was way more
patient probably than most people would
have been up to that point so I don't
blame him and you I apologize for any
disrespect she said to him I just you
know it's it's really my fault I should
have brought her here um to because I
know that I KN I knew this was going to
happen down deep I knew I knew this was
happen listen to me cuz you're not
listening to anyone this is why you are
where you are listen the best thing you
can do for yourself when you get to jail
do not fight with anyone rap no nobody's
going to rape you that's no they're not
sopia people are going to touch me she
can't she needs to go
to
she's no do not make it worse on your
you fight people when you get there
you're going to have more charges okay
can you please I'm so scared why can't I
just go home don't be scared you're
going why can't I just go home you you
made it yes you did ma'am I'm sorry he
would like talk to you right now okay
Luke don't go away